efectivamente nosotros tenemos la misma
impresión el ritmo con el que van
creciendo las emisiones de gas efecto
invernadero es impresionante por lo
tanto cualquier plazo y que signifique
postergar este tipo de medidas a
a un año como el año 2050 es una
diferencia es un diferencial muy
significativo el panel científico de
Naciones Unidas ha indicado que tenemos
una ventana de oportunidad muy corta
para hacer las reducciones de gases de
efecto invernadero en el corto plazo de
tal forma de no hipotecar el futuro de
las próximas generaciones por lo tanto
si bien es cierto este plebiscito este
referéndum que hace Suiza es importante
como un mecanismo político para
sensibilizar a la población creemos que
el plazo que se da es muy corto Ahora
hay que por el al mismo tiempo hay que
reconocer que el esfuerzo que está
haciendo Suiza a través de este de este
referéndum tiene que ver con reducir
emisiones
a tal de tal forma de que se neutralicen
con las que se emiten es decir no van a
ir a cero sino que van a ir a un punto
de encuentro entre las emisiones que se
emiten a la atmósfera por parte de la
actividad económica y social versus la
que el planeta en la naturaleza Es capaz
de absorber ahora eso tiene múltiples
implicancias tenemos tenemos la noción
Valentina
de que
venimos de dos años en que todos los
gobiernos nacionales locales regionales
provinciales han intentado
convocar a las sociedades a través de
la convocatoria y la denuncia por parte
de la crisis climática
creemos que esta referéndum va en la
misma dirección de sensibilización de la
sociedad sin sin embargo tenemos que
observar que la próxima cumbre de cambio
climático va a ser en Arabia Saudita y
la va a dirigir el presidente de la
petrolera de ese país por lo tanto hay
un múltiples contradicciones en las
cosas que van sucediendo en el mundo
bueno la propuesta incluye como lo
decíamos ayudas por 3.200 millones de
euros esto en 10 años Es suficiente esa
cantidad para sustituir los sistemas
tradicionales por otros menos
contaminantes
incluso desde los países de en vías de
desarrollo como como los nuestros Yo
vivo en Chile sabemos que esos montos
esas cifras son absolutamente
insuficientes para provocar cambios
verdaderos para mover la aguja como se
dice en ingeniería es dificilísimo que
con con esos plazos tan largos Y con
esos montos tan agotados puede
efectivamente hacerse algo significativo
sin embargo eso no es la única mirada
también hay que hay que reconocer que
hay una señal por esta vía que esos
montos pueden ir incrementándose en el
tiempo así que por lo tanto hay una ahí
una oportunidad implícita señora Andrade
usted muchas gracias por su análisis y
por compartirlo con nosotros en France